Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Oggi stiamo
per fare la storia della gastronomia di
Cucina Buttata, perché? Perché in passato
abbiamo provato a fare la carbonara
francese, abbiamo provato la pizza con
l'ananas e sotto abbiamo ricevuto anche
dei commenti di persone che dicevano "Sì
vabbè ma non si possono criticare troppo
queste persone perché giustamente non
essendo italiane non è che sappiano
benissimo cosa stanno facendo". Ecco
perché mi sono detto "Va bene, perché non
proviamo a fare un qualcosa che fanno
all'estero, che in realtà non è vero che lo fanno all'estero
Il Crispy lo fanno solo in Italia(Chef Rico)
Perché non provare a fare un
qualcosa che fanno solo in italia
In realtà era da tanto tempo che volevo provare a
prendere un panino di una catena di un
fast food e tentare di rifarlo in casa. E'
uno dei miei panini preferiti, è il Crispy McBacon
Il problema è che la salsa del Crispy McBacon
è stata per anni una specie di segreto
di Fatima, i cui ingredienti erano tipo
la ricetta della Coca Cola, nascosti al
mondo intero, ma di recente, non so quanto,
recente sono usciti gli ingredienti e ho
visto su internet il video di un
collega, lo Chef Roberto Valbuzzi che
proprio nel profilo ufficiale di
McDonald's, quindi stiamo parlando di cioè
non so come dire, approved by McDonald's,
quindi non si può scherzare adesso se
questa salsa non viene come deve venire,
perché io veramente sono qui per giocare
seriamente, ho visto il suo video e quindi ho deciso
di fare questa salsa e provare ad
assemblarla nel panino. A parte che c'è
un botto di roba dentro questa salsa
del Crispy McBacon, te lo credo che
era impossibile da rifare, perché per
farla avremo bisogno di tre uova, olio di
semi di arachide, aceto, senape,
concentrato di pomodoro, cetriolini
e te lo aspettavi? Aglio in polvere, capperi e
questa cosa che non pensavo esistesse
in cucina che è l'estratto di carne, che
per assurdo si trova pure nei
supermercati credo nascosta da qualche parte
Separiamo i tuorli. Gu il grembiule (Chef Rico).
Lanciamelo, lanciami il grembiule
Ok. Iniziamo quindi, 3 uovi, 50 g di
senape. Come faccio a pesare la senape?
Ah ho un'idea. Lo tari... ho capito l'idea geniale(Chef Mario) Weila (Chef Rico)
Hai detto
che è molto senaposa vero? Perché noi abbiamo degli...
All'interno proprio delle sedi di McDonald's c'è Enrico che tossisce girando su
se stesso. Abbiamo un laboratorio noi di
esperti, quindi metteremo meno senape
e meno capperi, al limite li aggiungiamo. Non mi sembra una mossa saggia eh (Chef Rico)
Anche il tuo parlare non mi sembra
saggio. Te lo credo che è senaposa
E' già troppa secondo me. 13 grammi intanto. Si fa sotto in tempo a raggiungere ma a
togliere... 30 grammi di concentrato di pomodoro... i capperi so
tanto forti. Da qui sembrano tipo i cereali quelli lì, le paline di cioccolato (Chef Rico)
Da qui sembrano caccole ...7 grammi io ci metto invece
che 20, 3 cetriolini. I cetriolini secondo me ci stanno
Sono meno incisivi di quello che
m'aspettavo. Sto cambiando un po' le dosi
mi sento... chiamatemi Ronaldo, non il calciatore. Aglio in polvere a buffo?
Devi vedere come ci stanno bene i miei denti. Sac...10 grammi di agro di spirito, tra
parentesi aceto. E' come se dicessi
"Quanto mi piace il tuo conserva caccole"
Si dice "naso", cioè nel senso perché? Ce ne metto
pochissimo ragazzi. Sembrava pipì (Chef Rico)
Sembrava meno (Chef Mario). Stop stop. Sembrava Gianmarco
Sale affumicato. Dov'è il sale affumicato?
Eh l'ho confuso (Chef Mario)...con che cosa l'hai confuso? Con la cipolla
Beh sono molto simili il sale e la cipolla. Vabbè noi metteremo del sale normale, voglio dire un po' di sale
affumicato. Un pizzico tanto ce sta il cappero (Chef Mario)
Ah è vero c'è il cappero. 150
millilitri di speranza. Utilizzerò una
tecnica speciale, cioè prima frullo tutto,
vedo a che tassello sta e poi aggiungo i 150 millilitri
ok? No no prima metti 150 millilitri in un contenitore e
poi mentre frulli (Chef Rico)...troppo tardi
Io sto aggiungendo un po' di senape a c**o. Guarda 150 so tanti. Si...Stop. Non abbiamo messo l'estratto di
carne. Che dite che se lo metto adesso è un casino? Ehehhehhe (Chef Rico e Mario)
A rigà, ma che è successo. L' estratto di
carne potrebbe cambiare il risultato
ancora in meglio.
Sono curioso perché io l'ho già assaggiata
questa salsa (Chef Mario). Fammi assaggiare (Chef Rico). E' più buona la tua. Ci si avvicina
Secondo me dovresti mettere più senape. Pure secondo me più senape. Che c***o, il sale affumicato
ci stava bene in tutto questo (Chef Mario). Si, un po' di affumicato, grazie. Il sale fa uscire i sapori (Chef Rico)
Ci si avvicina un sacco. Forse col sale
affumicato sarebbe stato ancora più
simile. Partiamo con l'assemblamento , cuciniamo e
facciamo. Devi prima fare infatti... cuocere (Chef Rico). Si, come non detto
A questo punto iniziamo a cucinare gli
ingredienti principali del Crispy. Noi
abbiamo trovato un bacon particolarmente
spesso, quello che dovremmo fare adesso è
trovare un metodo quindi per appiattirlo.
Credo di avere in mente un'idea. Piazzate
poi una pellicola sopra le fette in modo da
coprirle perfettamente. Ok? Così, e...
Molto più sottili di prima. Sempre stesso
procedimento di prima ragazzi
Coprite... Molto più sottili. La cosa positiva anche che
muovendovi in cucina, facendo questa cosa
iniziate a bruciare anche le calorie che
assumerete a breve. So sottili?(Chef Rico)
Sono molto più sottili si, sono molto più sottili. Pierfra ha
la bistecchiera... e glie la puliamo bene sì
Noi abbiamo la fortuna di avere una
bistecchiera, quindi utilizzeremo quella
altrimenti usate una griglia normale e...ciao.
Intanto prendo i panini e li dividono a
metà. Questi forse li dovresti spiaccicà per aumentà un po' il
volume, però poi così' forse li rompi (Chef Mario). Non si spiaccicano
Fa parte della ricetta dimenticarsi la cappa spenta? (Chef Rico)
Questi devono diventare incartapecoriti.
Se la trovate al supermercato al posto
di queste prendete quella nelle
confezioni proprio sottile sottile
sottile, noi non abbiamo trovato. Abbiamo optato per comunque pancetta di qualità
sempre nelle nostre cucine, insieme ad
hamburger di carne chianina, sempre nelle
nostre cucine. Ammazza Chef Mario. Vedi?
Ancora più sottile
No no non sono brutte affatto.
Guardalo. Che gli dici scusa? Bellissimo (Chef Mario)
Iniziamo nel frattempo a studiare come
dovrà essere assemblato, quindi ho qui
una foto del Crispy. Pane, bacon,
hamburger, formaggio, hamburger, salsa, pane
Io non ho mai visto Chef Mario e Chef Rico così felici di questa cucina
Uuu di già. Incominciamo quindi a creare il primo strato come se fosse....no si brusca il pane Gu (Chef Rico)
Cacchio è vero mi sono dimenticato che dovevo bruscarlo. Vai con Dio
In questo modo ne abbiamo uguali tutti, però non entrano è vero
Nonono. Enrico non entrano, no no. Sono intere quelle del Crispy
Non entrano! Eh è de coccio ogni tanto questo (Chef Mario)
Io non sono d'accordo, perché le piegano dentro. Non è la ricetta del Crispy (Chef Rico)
Ah ma guarda invece i panini al latte li trovi
proprio da McDonald. Devi salutare la
padella
Secondo me sai cosa puoi fare un secondo prima di levarli? Li giri e ci metti sopra il formaggio (Chef Mario)
Ma il sale l'hai meso? EHHH? Allora? (Chef Rico)
Regà, io li ho già in bocca, capito?
Ricordati poi di aprire il coso. (Chef Rico)              Ricordati di chiudere la bocca. Ma gli metto doppia
sottiletta perché sono molto piccole queste. Esatto (C Mario). Il Crispy ne ha una! (C Rico)
Enrico io ti odio
Il pane il pane controlla il pane Gu (Chef Rico)...Si Chef...non chiudere poi eh
A me piace molto questa divisione che ha
fatto Guglielmo invece (Chef Mario)
Essere quattro fratelli vuol dire che
automaticamente se non fai tutto uguale
t'ammazzi
Guarda è perfetta la carne anche
rispetto al pane. Mi sto eccitando (Chef Mario)
Meglio di quelli del Mac (Chef Rico). Io metto
questi da parte un secondo e finisco di
assemblare questo qua. Metti l'hamburger
sopra, abbondi con la salsa ragazzi, io
ce ne metterei così. Mettila sul pane no? (Chef Rico). Mi ero dimenticato...ok
Ok. Nooo, è delizioso! Allora lasciamo andare intanto gli
altri due hamburger e velocissimo assembliamo anche gli altri
Questo era il Crispi McBacon fatto in casa, è
un tripudio di roba. Finalmente Guglielmo! Direi che
è arrivato il momento di assaggiarlo ragazzi. Alla vostra ragazzi. Alla vostra. Cin cin, cin cin
Guarda  che la salsa ci sta tutta. Madonna regà è buonissimo. No ragazzi fatelo a ca...mamma mia!
Regà è bono vero. Pazzesco. Ragazzi taggatemi su Instagram se lo fate, ci prendiamo una pausa lunga una
settimana per mangiare e digerire questo
coso qui. Continuate a iscrivervi, attivate la
notifica se non volete perdere nessun video.
Ci vediamo la prossima domenica domenica
Ciao. Questo è il sapore del successo
Madonna!